good afternoon and welcome to the FA
Hyack auditorium and the Cato Institute
appreciate your coming out today this is
a really important topic the I have a
book form here for the human cost of
welfare by Phil Harvey and Lisa Conyers
for those folks who are following this
online you can follow along on twitter
at hashtag Cato events and or hashtag
the human cost of welfare now the US
federal government last year spent
roughly six hundred and eighty eight
billion dollars to fund more than 100
anti-poverty programs federal and our
state and local governments rather spent
an additional 300 billion dollars on
those and other programs that means the
government is spending close to a
trillion dollars every year fighting
poverty if you want to go all the way
back to 1965 when Lyndon Johnson
declared war on poverty we've spent some
22 or 23 trillion dollars fighting
poverty well what have we really
accomplished over that period of time if
you use the Census Bureau's official
poverty numbers poverty rates have
barely budged and even if you use the
sort of alternative poverty measures
which are more accurate and take into
account non-cash benefits and things
like that taxation and other things you
find that progress against poverty
really stalled out somewhere in the
1970s and it's been pretty flat
ever since we're spending more and more
money every year and getting fewer and
fewer results but as bad as that is for
taxpayers and for the fiscal balance
sheet of the US government
the real problem is that it's bad for
the people living in poverty because not
only are we spending money and not
helping them in many cases we may
actually be making their situation worse
or at least that's the case that's
argued by Phil and Lisa in their book
and so we're thrilled to have them with
us today to talk a little bit about the
studies they've done the people they've
talked to the fantastic opportunity
they've given to give actual voice to
people living in poverty and people on
welfare to tell their own stories and so
we're very happy to have them with us
today and they're gonna tell us a little
bit about this then we're gonna have
some conversation and then we will get
you folks involved as well Phil Harvey
is the chief sponsor of the DKE Liberty
project which is an advocacy group that
raises awareness about liberty and
freedom in the United States he's the
author of a number of other books
including what every child be wanted how
social marketing is revolutionizing
contraceptive use around the world and
government creep what the government is
doing that you don't know about he
writes for The Huffington Post Forbes
and other publications and profiles have
appeared in The Economist the chronicle
of philanthropy and Mother Jones quite a
cross-section their publications he's
chairman and the board of dkt
international and Lisa Conyers is the
director of policy studies for dkt
Liberty project she works on topics like
welfare policy inequality and civil
liberties she has a bachelor's degree
from George Mason University and a
master's in management from the
University of Maryland she's a
consultant and ghostwriters work focuses
on economics and public policy issues
this is a really terrific book there
will be a signing later on if you
haven't bought one already I urge you to
do it and in the meantime let's hear
from the authors of it will start with
Phil Harvey
[Applause]
thank you all for coming out thank you
for being here on what started out to be
a very rainy day it isn't any longer
which is which is good thanks to the
Cato Institute for arranging this and
making it possible and special thanks to
to Michael Tanner Michael has written
studied lectured widely on subjects
relating the welfare and poverty in the
United States and his work has greatly
informed our book and we're especially
grateful to him for that
we'll talk a little bit today about the
the basic issues outlined in our in our
book issues relating to welfare and its
problems
we'll talk quickly about the welfare
state and the extent to which the United
States is becoming one the correlation
between the rise in welfare and the drop
in workforce participation in the United
States the extent to which people on
welfare feel trapped and in many cases
are trapped in a cycle of welfare and
poverty and dependence and we'll discuss
briefly the benefits cliff which is one
of the rain' one of the principal
reasons for that feeling that sensation
of entrapment that so many of those who
Lisa interviewed expressed first let's
take a quick look go ahead and a quick
look at the relationship between welfare
spending and defense spending in the
United States it seems to me that given
the fact that America spends almost as
much as the rest of the world put
together on
that the fact that welfare expenditures
are now overtaking have often overtaken
already and are destined to overtake
defense spending even more as the years
go by in the future means that we have
come a very long way indeed to becoming
a welfare state because it is now a
larger obligation than than defense the
next slide shows the inverse correlation
between increases in welfare
expenditures this is a particularly
steep increase the blue line is food
stamp the food stamp program which is
skyrocketed more than some of the others
but it makes the point the red line is a
workforce participation that is the
percentage of adult Americans who are
either working or looking for work this
does not prove causation but we think
that the correlation between these two
items is not entirely coincidental as as
Mike mentioned welfare spending at the
federal level is now nearly seven
hundred billion dollars a year and our
feeling after doing the research and
Lisa doing over a hundred interviews
with welfare beneficiaries is that the
cost to us as taxpayers while it's very
very high is not as bad as the cost
being paid by the beneficiaries of this
program and I'll explain why we feel
that way
two principal reasons for this sense of
being trapped in poverty which people
hate of being dependent on the
government which people hate two of the
main reasons are the benefits cliff and
the culture of the welfare system itself
the benefits cliff is that point as
perceived by people receiving welfare
payments and other benefits as the point
at which when they earn too much money
they're going to lose their benefits
perhaps unpredictably and perhaps
suddenly the rules are there but they
are very complicated and hard to figure
out one woman Lisa interviewed quoting
her case worker said oh no no no you're
earning a little money now where we're
gonna have to cut your benefits now that
woman is afraid to earn any of money at
all exactly the opposite of what I think
people in poverty want to do themselves
and exactly the opposite of what we
would like for them to be able to do now
I should interject here that this cycle
of poverty and dependency is is not true
of all welfare beneficiaries the safety
net for some people works the way it's
supposed to you lose a job you go on
food stamps for three four or five
months you get another job and you go
off and that part of the say that aspect
for those people the safety net works
the way it's supposed to and I don't
think we want to imply that welfare is a
trap for everyone for for a significant
number it is not but we now see more and
more people on four three four five six
years and and that is the population
that we are particularly concerned about
and the population that is frankly
miserab
we've been warned over the years by
people who are in concerned with welfare
issues of the dangers involved and we're
seeing some of the dangers taking place
today one of the most articulate
spokespersons on this subject was
President Franklin Roosevelt who
referred to relief as it was called then
as a subtle narcotic I think a very
insightful a description a destroyer of
the human spirit he said undermining
dignity and self-respect we must
preserve self-respect Roosevelt said
self-reliance courage and determination
so he understood the dangers and was
very very concerned about them
how does welfare wide as welfare why
does dependence financial dependence on
the government have these enervating and
and and deeply negative effects it's
simply because all of us want to
accomplish things in life all of us want
to be able to say I did that I raised a
family I supported my family I got my
kids into college I learned to play the
saxophone it's expressed in many
different ways but we all need earned
accomplishment to make our lives of
worthwhile and that is exactly the
element that is missing in the lives of
those who depend heavily on welfare one
of the women Lisa interviewed expressed
this fact extremely well and I just want
to read her quote because I think it
illustrates both the the negative side
of being dependent and the positive side
of working your way out and I quote here
this is a woman in Decatur Illinois I
remember that first paycheck when I went
back to work like it was yesterday
one hundred seventy seven dollars not
much right but
was mine and I took it home and showed
it to the kids and it made me feel good
inside my kids they need so many things
diapers toys shoes clothes and they need
me to provide for them and it gives me a
lot of pride to do that instead of them
seeing mama cashing welfare checks I
think that encapsulate s' the human part
of this of this dilemma the answer as
the lady from Decatur suggests for most
Americans most of the time the answer to
the need and that the the need for
earned earned accomplishment is a job
not for everybody but for most people it
is paid work and the system the welfare
system is conspicuously bad at getting
people out of welfare and into work one
of the people we encountered was a man
named angel had been on welfare for many
many many years and he was just angry
about this fact he said you go to the
welfare office they should post jobs
there should be on the bulletin board
there should be jobs available in the in
this community except if they don't you
go in on a bulletin board it says need
help with food stamps need need Medicaid
assistance nothing about jobs and that
is the other aspect of this form of
entrapment the whole system including
recruiting government workers sponsoring
bingo nights for seniors to get them to
come in and sign up for food stamps for
heaven's sakes now there's been some
pushback on that recently I'm very glad
to see it that that recruiting is taking
this business a little too far but still
the psychology of the system is more
welfare more different welfare programs
and nothing about jobs and work the only
program that has a job training and job
placement component
is Tam TANF the program that replaced
aid to families with dependent children
back in 1996 and that program has become
very very small it's only two or three
percent of the total welfare package now
so these other programs have overtaken
it and they do not have work components
there's one program in the system one
big program the Earned Income Tax Credit
which does require work and earning in
order to enjoy that benefit and we think
that shows the way to greatly improve
the system and that using that as a
model we may be able to come up with
ways of making this situation a whole
lot better thanks
[Applause]
I just have one slide it's pretty simple
first of all I just want to thank
everybody for coming out today it's a
Monday and this is a great way to start
the week talking about interesting ideas
and I want to thank Michael Tanner again
for having us
and Cato Institute - I just love that
they put on these events and get us all
together to talk about things so I'm
delighted to be here and I'm gonna talk
just really briefly about more of the
philosophical underpinning behind our
book because it's based on a pretty
philosophical idea and then I'll just
speak briefly about the methodology how
I did how we did the book how I did my
travels and then we'll just open it to
questions from Michael and from you guys
so um the reason I picked this slide is
because that's basically the the
philosophy behind the book is that we
have the right to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness but most especially
what we're interested in is the pursuit
of happiness and the idea is that we're
what we want to look at is if we're if
we have the right to the pursue
happiness what does that mean what does
it mean to be happy what does it take
for all of us to be happy and then once
we decide on that what does the welfare
system have to do with that will it help
us be happier or will it not help us be
happier is it helping the people who are
on it leave satisfying lives and pursue
happiness or not so that's the question
that we wanted to answer with this book
and so as far as happiness goes we
aren't the first people to come up with
the idea that what we do for a living is
really essential to human happiness what
we do to self actualize what we do to
get that earned success that Arthur
Brooks talks about and scholars from
Aristotle to you know Socrates and on
have all talked about happiness and they
all look at this kind of like what is it
what do we need and we all know I mean
if I were to ask you probably the first
question I would ask you is what do you
do right are you an artist are you a
teacher are you a writer are you a
policy analyst are you you know and
that's how we identify with our who we
are and what we are doing with our lives
and so if we agree that we have the
right
to pursue happiness and if we agree that
happiness is tied up with what we do for
a living and how we earn our way then
what is a welfare system look like under
those parameters is it does it help
people be happy or does it not and so
that was basically the underlying
philosophy behind this book so yes
there's a lot of Policy Analysis in
there there's plenty of charts for
policy wonks and all that kind of stuff
but it's also a deeply philosophical
thought an idea that we wanted to
address so what we found out when we
started looking at welfare programs is
that they actually put people in a
position where work is a threat rather
than a reward it's risky to go to work
you'll lose benefits if you go to work
and the rules are really strict and very
hard to deal with so when you hear about
for example you know a lot of people are
on welfare are working you know what
about the working poor they're working
right but the problem is that they're
being told that they can work you know a
few hours a week or a month that they
can earn so much but if they go over
that you're off the world and I met a
lot of people that had tripped up over
those rules you know a gift from an aunt
or somebody dying in the family and
leaving them money that suddenly threw
them out of all these programs and left
them in a position where they were had
to get back on it took several months
and so the whole psychology about work
changes when you're on these programs
all of a sudden the value of the
programs becomes greater than a job that
you could get and so for example Phil
talked a little bit about the welfare
cliff and the director of Health and
Human Services in the state of
Pennsylvania looked at this he decided
to actually do an example of a woman
that would be in this position and what
it would look like and so he took a
mother with two children a single mom
with two kids living in the suburbs
she'd be getting cash assistance she'd
be getting food stamps she'd be getting
WIC which is additional food for her
energy
infant she'd be getting housing she'd be
getting she'd be on Medicaid and doing
the math adding up the value of all
those benefits
he found that you'd have to earn close
to fifty nine thousand dollars a year to
replace those benefits so if somebody
wants to go to work
and they're offered a job and it's not
and it's not going to cover the value of
those benefits all of a sudden they make
a very rational decision based on the
incentives to not work and and that's
scary because maybe in the short term we
think well that's okay you know we're
helping them out we're giving them you
know they're getting support so that's
good right because we don't want the
poor to not get support but we're
actually telling them not to go to work
we also do this in the disability system
any of you who are familiar with anybody
on disability you know that you're told
not to go to work if you get on
disability because you have a good
chance of losing your benefits and so we
take people that are disabled but would
like to work and make work into a risk
so that's basically the underlying
philosophy behind this book that we
believe that we do all have the right to
pursue happiness and that happiness
requires work and earned success and
that welfare systems get in the way of
that so in a nutshell if you got that
you got the whole premise of the book
briefly I'm gonna just tell you that as
far as my role in the book Phil and I
did a lot of Policy Analysis together
but we wanted to do a book that was a
little bit different than most of the
work that comes out of DC which is very
heavy on policy analysis but is maybe
missing that you know what's it like how
do these policies actually play out in
real life for the real people who are
affected so I traveled all over the
country and the Northeast South the
southwest
you know the Pacific Northwest
California Hawaii I went all over the
place and I went into soup kitchens and
homeless shelters and tent cities and
bus stops wherever I could find people
that would be willing to talk to me and
I just asked them if they would be
willing to talk to somebody who was
writing about welfare about what their
life was like and surprisingly people
were perfectly happy to talk to me and
show me their math and what they were
doing and what they were living on and
how many dollars they got every month
and so then we took all those stories
and we added them to our policy analysis
so the book is not just a dry sort of
you know food stamps cost us this much
and and this is how it works out and it
then goes on with stories from the road
so we think that that's a really unique
contribution to this whole field of
policy research and we were delighted to
do it and I think I'm
so I'm going to open questions from
Michael I think I've done what I was
supposed to do one of the really
fascinating things about this book is
the fact that you did talk to actual
participants in the system and gave them
a voice too much in Washington to be
throwing wrong
these are called lavalieres I don't know
who lavaliere was they're not loving
ears essentially you you gave voice to
people actually in the system which is
so unusual that would part a welfare
debate we tend to think folks drive
physics so I'm curious in terms of this
what you learned about why people are
poor I mean essentially if you look at
the big debate academically right now
there's once I've talked about others
poverty is essentially structural it's
based on racism and sexism and so are
things beyond individuals control and
then there's sort of another side of it
as well it's it's bad behavior on the
part of the poor they've done bad things
in their life made mistakes made bad
decisions and that's why they're poor
you actually interacted with the poor
what what did you see in those those
regards well I think people are poor
because they don't have any money but I
think that you know it's a very
complicated subject and it's everything
from bad decision making I mean
certainly I saw people who had made bad
decisions and ended up you know in a
position where they couldn't nobody
would hire them or or or they had you
know addiction issues where they
couldn't hold a job I mean there are all
kinds of reasons why people are poor so
I don't think there's anyone I think the
fact that I did my travels during the
during the recession made it kind of
interesting because I was seeing people
who had just I mean there was a lot of
job loss during that time and I was
traveling around the country during that
time and people were saying well yeah
it's easy to talk about this but there's
no jobs available like what am I
supposed to do you know so that made it
kind of a little bit more complicated
but so I guess the answer is I mean for
many decisions and for many reasons you
know but I will say that the vast
majority of the people that I
interviewed would much rather be working
I heard over and over and over again I
would much rather be doing work and it
didn't matter what kind of work any kind
of work then then having to be on these
programs and you know some people say oh
well there's those people out there they
just don't want to work I may be
expected to see a little bit of that and
I'm sure it's out there but I didn't
people like that I melt met people that
were really trying hard and they didn't
want that their preference would have
been to be working the war on drugs has
certainly contributed the fact that so
many particularly young black men are
spending time in jail
clearly find it harder to get a legal
work as a result of that and that has
added I mean that is another cycle of
poverty and incarceration but it is
certainly added to the to the poverty
cycle in the United States yeah I think
that's that's pretty undeniable the
other thing you make such a strong case
in this book for is what in a common
talk about the marginal tax rate or the
fact that people when they earn a
certain amount of money they start
losing their benefits they're also taxed
on that income very quickly and the fact
that that discourages work I think is
pretty undeniable we made that case many
people who recall in a study called the
work versus welfare trade-off which is
widely criticized and I think then the
Pennsylvania study and some stuff out
CBO and stuff and uh figures in Ohio
study also that sort of confirmed where
we were coming down on that and then
your book I think really builds on that
work what would you though recommend as
an alternative to that I mean so that I
know that when we brought out that study
some folks on the Left said well the
answer is therefore we have to raise
wages we need a higher minimum wage or
we need more guaranteed benefits of some
kind other people said what means we
need to cut welfare benefits back down
down to a lower level some people talked
about the Earned Income Tax Credit what
do you recommend as an answer well
certainly making welfare point toward
work is is an important part of that the
present system is anti work it's it's
almost a war on
work and that's insane at the very very
least we ought to be helping people get
out of the system and and and into paid
employment I did mention the EITC it
does have the effect of topping up wages
and that I think is is very good it's a
cumbersome system that requires filing a
income tax return
it was basically designed originally to
refund to low-income people the any
federal income tax that had been
withheld from their wages but it now
tops up those amounts by considerably
more than has ever been withheld it's
the right idea because it makes work pay
it has contributed very substantially to
getting people out of welfare and into
work and us to to take a job that may
pay seven or eight dollars an hour but
when you get the EITC benefit it's the
same again with this somewhat cumbersome
process as earning twelve or fourteen
dollars an hour and that is I think the
right way to go about it
I certainly agree with you Michael that
that this plethora of benefits housing
food etc is very patronizing and that to
the extent we can give people money and
let them make their own decisions about
their own lives and set their own
priorities that that is also a move in
the right direction and that subsidizing
wages is one way of doing that we've
seen some states Kansas and Missouri and
others coming down with also the drug
testing of recipients the prohibition on
buying seafood with food stamps or
limiting people on TANF to twenty five
dollars a day taking out a cash machine
despite the fact that high fees to go
with banking and so on you see this sort
of punitive approach as being a
effective or being counterproductive
through what way the people actually
have to live it's dumb yeah well and
yeah I guess I would agree with Phil
that I mean people aren't just because I
mean they can make good decisions they
will make good decisions and they don't
need a lot of patronizing in order to do
that
then and it doesn't seem to be working
very well in the places that it's been
tried I mean it tends to get passed and
then immediately you know rescinded so I
mean I know you do describe yourself in
the in the book as being at least open
to the idea of a guaranteed national
income to replace the current pile of
welfare programs we have on that one of
the big problems with that is trying to
make the numbers on that work as you
know we did a study here on that and
found we couldn't find a way to make it
make the numbers work but is that
something you're open to yes I mean
there there are two kinds and I think we
need to distinguish the the the system
which was then I think called negative
income tax which topped up believe me
the freedom an idea which topped up
people's wages turned out to be a work
killer and for the very simple reason
that if you were making nine thousand
dollars and the established level was
twelve thousand dollars and the
government gives you three thousand
dollars under those circumstances you
have no incentive at all to make that
three thousand dollars yourself because
you're going to end up with the same
amount of money anyway the straight cash
benefits are I think the the purest form
is the charles murray plan in his book
in our hands which is to give everybody
ten thigh every adult American ten
thousand dollars a year and nothing else
this is affordable if you don't give it
to the truly wealthy and I think that
distinction does have to be made because
if you're giving ten thousand dollars a
year to millionaires
and everybody in between it does cost
too much but I we haven't really tested
this at all well and I agree with you
Michael has written a good deal about
this and some experiments on just giving
people money and letting him make their
own decisions
muri muri sets up some interesting
hypotheticals he says ten thousand
dollars a year of three or four of you
want to get together and rent a shack by
the on the beach and spend the rest of
your life surfing you can do that
nobody's going to tell you how to spend
the money there are no incentives to
work there no disincentives to work
there are no incentives to have children
there are no dis I mean it's it in that
respect is entirely neutral my resident
reservation about that having having
found the power of the relationship
between work and unhappiness in this in
doing this book is that too many people
wouldn't work and even though that would
be their own choice there's no guiding
hand telling them not to work but people
who aren't working generally aren't as
happy as people who are so I have that
concern but I do think we should test it
yeah I mean does seem that the studies
they were done in the 1970s by the MRD C
and others did shows these were the
negative income tax that it did have a
discouraging effect on work because they
caused that marginal tax rate problem
Murray I know suggested about twenty
five thousand dollars tax-free and then
he would start taxing above that but
you'd still have some sort of problems
with marginal tax rate yeah you would
would phase in there and if you tried to
get the ten thousand dollars everybody's
about four trillion dollars which is
truly unaffordable so making the numbers
work it seems to overcome theory on that
what about some of the other approaches
that are being talked about out there
one of the big things on the Republican
side now is to consolidate these
programs and to sort of block grant them
to the state Paul Ryan wants to do it
with a small number of programs
Marco rule
you only think it's suggested although
he hasn't really spelled out didn't
really spell out the details in his book
but kind of almost everything giving him
to the states in terms of a block grant
and then having some sort of standards
the states had to me to continue to
qualify would that be an approach that
you think that you would be in favor of
what did you hear at that at that
meeting in South Carolina I was on the
advisory council for Paul Brian's
poverty summit in North in South
Carolina in January where six of the
Republican presidential candidates came
and talked about poverty for a half a
day which was really cool
I mean Paul Ryan really had some you
know some energy in the room
unfortunately the six candidates that
came are no longer in the race and even
though the on the Democratic side they
were invited but chose not to attend so
I don't know where we stand with all
that but Mitch was there he's not quite
at standing but in terms of the block
grants to the states in our reading of
how these things play out for example
the 1996 welfare reforms
we're supposed to be welfare to welfare
to work they were all supposed to have a
work component you were supposed to you
know be given encouragement and ways to
get a job and the whole idea was that we
were going to end welfare as we know and
get everybody into work and then a lot
of those programs were sort of turned
over to the states for enforcement and
what happens on the state level is that
all of a sudden you're dealing with real
people and lo and behold their waivers
started happening so now if you look at
federal welfare programs as they
actually play out in the state's today
you find that even though something
comes in with rules from Washington when
it gets out to Iowa or Washington State
or wherever the state is dealing with
their population of people on welfare
and they adjust accordingly
so I have some you know some thought
some concerns about that but I do like
the idea of giving States more control
on the flip side so I'm kind of
schizophrenic on this because I think
that overall the states do deal with
their actual populations I mean when you
hear cases talk about people in his
state or you know bush or whatever their
populations
you know they adjust their programs to
meet their people so if they had more
freedom
do that maybe they would do it better
but unfortunately what I've seen so far
is that they tend to loosen the
requirements rather than tighten them
for the most part well I think one of
the good things we're gonna find here is
some interesting questions from the
audience so I want to turn it over to
them but before I do let me give you a
chance to defend yourselves against what
I think will be one of the criticisms of
your book and that is that there's a
certain amount of victim blaming that's
going on that it's it's essentially you
take a poor person living in the inner
city there they've had terrible
schooling because the inner city schools
are by and large lousy they're dealing
with the criminal justice system the war
on drugs that you've said there's no
jobs certainly in their neighborhood you
know you go to the area the area where
Freddie gray was killed up in Baltimore
for example there's not even a fast-food
door in that entire neighborhood no
supermarkets there's they're basically
no employment opportunities around there
these are not people living in the
suburbs and then you're saying okay get
a job
pull yourself up by your bootstraps is
that a fair charge to put on that poor
person to do that and aren't you in in
essence somehow saying that they're
behaving badly by not doing that well I
lost my train of thought and as far as
the the job situation in inner cities
it's Phil and I were it we did a book
event Baltimore couple weeks ago and we
had a bunch of people in the audience
who were talking about you know how they
wish that there were more jobs you know
there for people to to have and that
that was an issue but they also agreed
that yeah they'd rather be working so
even those who aren't able to find jobs
I mean our point is those folks would
rather be working it's not that they're
that they're living there because they
choose to live in you know inner-city
neighborhoods that don't have any jobs
available and still the the idea that
they do want to work is still there
number two when I traveled around the
country I met people that I would ask
why they wouldn't move for work because
you know at that time North Dakota had
0% unemployment or something
Kilis you know and i would meet people
in Alabama and I'd say you know what
about moving for work which is something
that we used to do a lot I did it
growing up and benefits kind of hold you
back from that because it's really hard
to get off those benefits and go move to
another state and all of a sudden you've
got to reapply and so it gets very
complicated so but as far as blaming the
victim I think that that's exactly what
we're not doing we're saying we care
very deeply about these people and that
they have just as much right to
happiness as we do I mean why do they
have any more or less right to the same
things that we have I mean I have the
right to happiness they do too and so to
banish them or to leave them to ignore
them to say well you live in our
neighborhood you know too bad for you
no I mean I think Phil and I are arguing
very strongly that we care about them a
lot and we want them to be happy and we
believe that their happiness will come
from the more key the the worst thing it
seems to me that you can do to somebody
is to put them in a situation where
they're gonna be in a perpetual cycle of
dependency and poverty that's cruel and
we shouldn't do it the best thing that
you can do in this context it seems to
me is make work more attractive there's
little to be said or doing more to
create dependency that doesn't lead to
satisfying lives it leads exactly the
other way so I don't see any blaming the
victim there it seems to me that the
idea that simply providing more benefits
to people is going to be good for them
and what we found is that it is not
that's a really important point all
right let's go to the the audience out
here if you can wait
have a microphone so that will come
around to just identify yourself as you
as they approach with the microphone and
then please keep it to a question and
not not a speech so right here in the
second row right there in the middle
right there one of you John Soliday in
the kana I'm an economist it's a
hypothetical question that's how I get
out here or get out of you're alive but
what happened if you cut all of it you
went back to 1960 is this a political
issue because that I'm thinking in terms
this is wagga die you know they're civil
society there's the family there are
other safety nets that are and Uncle Sam
what would this look like if you got rid
of the whole everything I mean I'm not
running for office well I think it's
it's a a fair question frankly and in
many respects there would be pluses but
let us say right off there would be some
destitution one of the things that has
been accomplished by the welfare system
although it could have been done other
ways is to virtually eliminate real
destitution in this country we don't
have people starving in the streets now
I don't think they would be if we ended
everything because Americans give away
350 billion dollars a year to private
charities and a great deal more of that
if we had no welfare a great deal more
of that would go to poverty and less
probably to the symphony and museums and
universities so that I think society
would adjust but there would be a period
there that would that would be rough for
some of people I do think that private
philanthropy could be taking up much
much more of of the welfare issue
and one of the recommendations we
discuss in in the book is giving people
a tax credit for donating to a list of
several thousand charities there's
always the problem of picking those
charities but instead of giving money to
the government for food stamps you could
give it to the charity of your choice
for assisting the poor and they would
have to use it for something related to
that purpose I think that would be a
good move one just a couple more things
I would add to that is that there's a
very robust underground economy so you
know there are there people are not
necessarily living on food stamps
they're living on food stamps and then
they're trading about it bartering and
doing all kinds of things so you know
the you have to keep that in mind number
two part of your savings would be a vast
array of government employees to
administer all these programs so they
don't lose their jobs which would mean
more unemployment but on the other hand
weed free up some money that was it
wasn't directly going towards support
anyway so I was gonna say in responded
that the consumption data if you look at
what the poor actually spend as opposed
to what their income is it's it's a some
cases like 7 times higher in terms of
consumption so it's significant the
other interesting thing and we go to a
Phil said it's if you looked at poverty
rates prior to 1965 they were coming
down steadily and they they continued to
come down through the early 1970s and
then they've pretty much leveled off
since then and you can argue even more
than the 65 to the mid 70s whether
that's due to welfare spending or to do
things like Civil Rights Act which
brought african-americans into the labor
force or the women's movement witching
proved women's earnings and so on so
there's not a whole lot of evidence to
suggest that additional welfare spending
at least today is is lowering poppy
significantly it did we have of course
got no longer have the Michael
Harrington style destitution that Phil
was talking about we're a third of a
American poor didn't have running
in their homes and so on that sort of
stuff is gone but there is question of
whether we're actually lifting people
out of poverty now with the programs we
have yeah a gentleman in the blue right
behind a previous speaker thank you what
what are your self just so weak Oh Jim
Lampard a friend of the author one of
the authors what what consideration have
you did you give or might you give to
things that would stimulate job creation
both by the private sector and you know
the old new dealer type public works
projects and that kind of thing of you
to me the from what I am familiar with
it's really difficult to find employment
under the circumstances of the low
income your very low income black areas
in people now being losing their jobs
because of the outflow of jobs to other
countries so did you give consideration
to that that instead of trying to give
people an incentive to find jobs give
incentives or put some kind of pressure
on the private sector to create plenty
of jobs for the people that we have and
the federal government in a time of very
low interest rates
the short answer Jim is is yes we have a
series of recommendations basically to
make it easier for business particularly
small business to create jobs we there's
an awful lot of policy now government
policy now that inhibits a job creation
the regulations on small manufacturing
businesses for example
are estimated to be something like 15 or
$20,000 per employee of simple
regulatory requirements so we have a
number of recommendations about that we
have almost absolute sweeping
recommendations about idiotic licensing
requirements this is a lot of that is is
state are originated but it in and when
you have to license things like flower
arranging and hair braiding and taking
care of horses teeth and other things
that requires that you you go to some
college some training course that costs
$1000
these are stopping people from getting
new businesses started and new
businesses are one of the life Bloods of
our economy so we have another number of
recommendations about that as to the
availability of work one of the positive
things that Lisa mentioned this two
minute ago is the people are finding
work and and not telling anybody about
it at least half the people she talked
to and we think this is this is in
indicative of the of the total
population we're working off the books
there's a big underground economy out
there and in a way that's good news
because the people that means that
people want to work and it means that
they're finding ways of of working out
men also bartering and exchanging as as
as Lisa said but well let me stop there
those are some of the the principal
things that that we suggest to to make
more jobs and the licensing is an area
of broad bipartisan agreement it's
something that even the White House has
spoken out on in fact about 30% of all
occupations in America now require some
sort of license permit or state approval
in order to participate in funeral
attendance
require a state license and then so just
don't die unapproved or something and
yeah up here in front and then we'll
move to the back next
hi Gary Merritt Thank You Phil and Lisa
very provocative I looking forward to
getting further into the book and
finding of the narrative having to do
with how we got to here with respect to
misbegotten political processes and
concepts that were embodied in law that
brought us to this place I suppose there
will be a narrow narrative arc on that
so we would better understand we've had
presidents who are Republican with
different types of Senate and House
arrangements and and all mixtures of
things since Franklin Roosevelt and yet
this has happened Republican Democrat
and bhaktavar so do you if you can
understand how we got to here it might
be those people could be rallied around
the idea that it hasn't worked out the
way they wanted and become part of a
constituency to change things yeah
we're not just right being about it well
I mean I think the way we the way we got
here is fairly straightforward as
society becomes wealthier people are
more and more you can say embarrassed
that there are poor among us or they are
simply more concerned or they simply
realize that we can afford programs to
assist the poor so people need food we
get food stamps people need medical care
we get Medicaid and so on I don't think
there's anything terribly
serious about that it is odd when you
ponder it a bit that in all the the
relatively prosperous Western
democracies including the famous
Scandinavia which is always used this is
an example of how government in this
regard can work as they became wealthier
instead of thinking well now the whole
society is wealthier so fewer people are
going to need welfare have decided
instead that as society becomes
wealthier we will use more of our wealth
to help the poor even though they need
it less then than they did before but
that's that happened here and and it has
it has happened in all the Western
democracies I don't think it's it's
terribly mysterious and the difference
is there are differences right and left
that is between conservative and liberal
views of all this but that I don't think
that's quite what you were asking time
for two or three more questions we'll
take two
and then David Basel you'll finish it up
Thank You gerald Chandler wouldn't you
agree that using the word poverty is
rather misleading because it's actually
a government assistance level and that
we have decreased poverty
you use the word destitution before and
we've certainly decreased that and that
what we actually do is keep raising the
level to that the government assistance
is allowed well it's it's a fair point a
number of scholars have hypothetically
asked will we continue providing welfare
when beneficiaries can afford second
homes and sailboats and mmin
it's an interesting question because the
the lifestyle of most poor Americans
today exceed middle-american standards
of 50 or 60 or 70 years ago
I mean having running water hot and cold
running water indoor plumbing a
television set a telephone a microwave
and and a computer would have looked
very very good to my parents when they
were young that's quite a long time ago
but relative poverty is a very deeply
ingrained belief in American society and
I think in in Western society generally
and as long as there are people who are
conspicuously more poor than most people
I I think that the concern will continue
to exist even though in absolute terms
you could argue that it doesn't yeah
Yeomans had his hand up a lot for a
while there
I'm Stephen Schaffer Minh with basic
income action and I was pleased here you
mentioned Charles Murray and the
negative income income maintenance
experiments from the 60s I just want to
see if you're following the discourse
about basic income in Europe and Canada
and many other places where this idea of
a guaranteed floor is gaining enormous
support there will be a referendum in
Switzerland in a couple of weeks
there are programs pilot programs
getting launched in Holland in England
in Canada there have been pilot programs
in India and even Namibia so just
wondering if you could comment on the
rest of the world and these ideas and
how they might provide insight for what
we're doing well I think you're right I
mean around the world people are it's a
sign of of the wealth in the world right
that we are at a point where we are even
considering a basic income for all
citizens for example and that's
wonderful news we've looked at various I
mean Phil has already talked about it
some but our concern is basically this
this it's sort of at war with our idea
that people need to be working to be
happy so if you just give them money and
and they can choose as Phil said you
know four guys get together and get a
beach house there's nothing wrong with
that but we have a sort of philosophical
question about well what does that mean
because we're not you know the minute
you start putting rules on it and saying
you have to work well then we're back to
what we're doing right now right so it
is it's very interesting and I think
Phil and I would agree that we're
excited to see these studies coming
about I think there needs to be a lot
more research and it is fascinating the
different countries of different places
they're all sort of reaching that point
at the same time and I'm just excited
that we have that kind of ability I mean
having grown up in the developing world
and I see how different it is now it's I
mean we've made a lot of progress I mean
there's a lot of problems all over the
world but Wow the fact that countries
like as varied as you just mentioned are
looking at it is I think awesome so
certainly we should give us some data to
begin to look at results as we see it
come out so many states Finland is
another place switch legs gonna lose the
referendum I mean it's just the nature
of Swiss democracy
you lose anything there's a probe first
time it's it's proposed the trek
experiment the Netherlands we should
have data within a couple of years and
Canada's still trying to figure out how
to did its how to devise their their
proposed experiment so we don't really
have data yet or these things aren't
really in place yet in any of these
places we're still talking about it but
it will provide some interesting data
about whether or not this is good
it also looks to whether these are sort
of add-on we're just tossing more
benefits into the pile whether we're
really talking about replacing the
existing welfare system which seems to
go with the fins seem to be moving
towards and their approach the Swiss we
have no idea actually what it's good to
because they left it all up to the the
Federal Council to actually develop so
that's one reason why it's going to
going to probably lose now that so let's
finish it up my colleague David Bose
with the last question of the of the
afternoon I actually have two questions
which may or may not be related number
one I was monitoring the Twitter feed on
the event and somebody posted a question
they're asking
was there any rigor any rigor or
sampling to the interviews you did and
are you trying to present them as
representative of something my own
question would be if I'm a person who
knows a fair amount about welfare has
has read a book or two a study or two
what's the most original or valuable
thing I would get out of this book they
may be related so okay so as far as
rigor no there was not a scientific
sampling done by state of who I talked
to this was what I would refer to as
random sampling because I randomly
walked around and ran into people so as
far as that that would be my answer
I interviewed whoever would talk to me
wherever I went I walked into lots of
different situations from Indian
reservations to tent cities in Seattle
where a lot of homeless lived to you
know it was I think it was
representative of the country which was
really important to me I mean I argued
pretty hard for
going all over the different regions
because I thought it was important but
now I didn't take you know five women
and five men from each state and of
different ages and and you know do
anything like that and then what I don't
remember the second question what's the
what's the most a different take away
why is this book different than the 250
other books on welfare that been read in
the last ten years well because we wrote
it I the the most surprising thing to me
and I think it comes through in the book
pretty strongly is the importance the
central importance of work to a decent
life I as a libertarian abhor
patronizing other people and if it
weren't for the fact that our welfare
system is incredibly patronizing right
now I wouldn't be suggesting things that
also seem patronizing but it does seem
to me and I think this emerges from the
book and it is very controversial but it
seems to me that human beings are
happier when they work and even when
they are forced to work even if they
don't feel like working there are those
of us who make our own mountains
sometimes I do and sometimes I don't but
a lot of the time what people react to
and deal with successfully our challenge
is put in front of them and it was an
eye-opener for me
and I think it comes through in the book
that a satisfying life requires work
even if it's unpleasant even if you
don't choose it it still seems to be
fundamental
to a decent and and happy life well as a
reader of the book and not one of the
authors and someone who's read a lot of
those studies in those books one of the
interesting things that I find the big
takeaway is those interviews in the
voice of the poor in here because you
read a lot of the books on on the Left
nickel-and-dime to some of the other
famous books and they talk they deal
with people you read a lot of books on
on our side of the debate and they deal
with numbers and the fact that this does
speak to the people and the people who
are hurt by the welfare system I do find
unique an important voice in this debate
and for those of you who want to read
that the book is the human cost of
welfare the authors are Phil Harvey and
Lisa Conyers and they will be upstairs
signing some books if you are selling
them so please join us for lunch and and
get your book signed thank you all very
much for coming
[Applause]